YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEONE
ROAMING AROUND THE RIM.PORTER J.
AND THE FLUSH, IN AND PASS.
BIYOMBO
TIME.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I WANTED KN
GET YOUR MONEY'S WORTH!
FIVE POINT GAME.
THAT IS SOMETHING NOBODY WAS SP
HE IS FEELING IT TONIGHT.
>> Alaa: EUBANKS A FIRST HALF.
ALAA, THIS ED
SAVED BY MILES BRIDGES WITH THE
WITH HANDS ON IT
AND JA MORANT WILL TAKE A SEAT.
CHARM.
LET'S SEE IT.
JEFF GREEN. DOING SOME DAMAGE
HERE IN THE THIRD PERIOD.
YOU ARE
YOU CANNOT GET A GUY WHO IS
HELPLESS.
WHEN YOU ARE JUMPING, YOU FOR T.
CAREER.D, 13 FOR ON THE OTHER
>> M. Jones: WHAT?
GOING.
LIKE THEY'RE PLAYING THROUGH
HIM.M
SHOOTING THREES, WH.INCREDIBLY
CONFIDENCE.NIS.
HEHE
SWITCH.
HE WENT TO SWITCH.
AND DOWN THE LANE!
STEVENS